did you sleep in your car or lock
yourself in a room
to get the feeling of being trapped at
any point
writing the script i mean when i was
writing i locked myself in a small room
mostly
uh no you know what i did it's funny i
owned the exact car that we used
and what i did do
is i would sometimes just go so
you know how do what can i use
you know i i picked the car for
for a few different reasons um
one you know as i was doing my research
uh
and where it was supposed to take place
in in norway
uh you know i this i saw this car as a
uh you know the land rover i'm i don't
even know if they want me to say atlanta
rover but i saw the
this car as as a car that would be
rented or would be used to kind of
off-road or go into kind of
you know mountains and do a little bit
of exploring
um it also was a car that had so many
windows
uh you know it had it was just it's a
wall of windows on every side and two
sunroofs
and i thought that would be very
uh advantageous for us
as far as lighting and uh you know just
giving making the environment feel you
know
still feel claustrophobic but kind of
bring you know the elements
closer feeling the snow right on top of
us
um and then also i had the car
so if uh you know we didn't raise enough
money and i needed to just
wreck my car i will i would
um but it was you know it was a it was
the perfect you know i went i showed it
to the dp and he was like oh yeah this
part this is perfect look at all these
windows and
you know uh it showed up when you google
pictured like when you google image
there you know
the area of norway like the car would
show up places so
um
but when i as i was writing i would go
into the car and i would sit in the
driver's seat and i would like okay so
they're here and this is what happens
and and you know how do what do i do
what can i do here like what would i do
where would i put things like where
would i do this um
there was a there's a moment in the film
that we all uh
not argued about we had one producer
who's always like i hate this scene
where you know you know this also wasn't
in the original script but
you know my one of my first things
reading and doing it was like
so where where do you go to the bathroom
in something like this and then i was
like in the car and i'm like so
i guess i would go back here and i would
put it in here and then i would
and then where would i want to put this
where would i want to put
are all of our bathroom waste like i
would want to separate that from
somewhere else like i'd probably want to
put my food
somewhere farther away from where my
bathroom waste goes
so you know did i sleep in the car
overnight to just kind of
feel what it's like no but i did go
constantly down to my car and sit in the
environment
and write and come up with ideas or like
go i'll go here and i would go there and
i would you know
and and and you know pull on this and
break this
and you know how can you get out this
way or you know
um so
it was very helpful to kind of put
myself in this space
for scene work for
uh you know action in in in
in the in writing um in blocking um
and definitely when it came to kind of
shot listing for the for the film
uh you know the dp and i would go look
at the car and you know
take our phones out and be like okay
like can we get a camera here and he'd
be like no because your phone is a lot
smaller than the camera so we got
you know we have to do this um but uh
it was it was it was great to have that
you know you can't always just put
yourself in in a in a
setting and and have it be as close to
you know what really
happens but i do i have found that when
writing other things you know
putting yourself even like kind of
taping out
an area or saying you know okay i'm in a
room that's only this big so
how do i imagine like what do i what can
i do in here or
or you know what would my character do
in this in
you know in this space and what was it
about the year
was it 2002 that you you felt you wanted
to do it
sort of you know was it because maybe
the technology wouldn't have been as
strong so they would have trouble
contacting someone i found that very
interesting i was actually intrigued by
that
you know it was 2002 it was it was 2002
and that goes back to
um it goes back to
the original concept of the movie
was you would flash to these interviews
of family members talking about what
happened in the car
and that would take place 15 years later
uh it was a there was a document
docume you know a docu-style interview
that would kind of cut in and out of the
movie
uh as they kind of reminisced about what
happened
uh without giving away kind of how
everything unfolded they'd kind of like
learn
you know they would you would they would
try to add a little backstory about the
characters as you
as the film progressed um
but in the end we ended up cutting all
of those interviews
and we had a lot of they were they were
amazing interviews and the actors
that we that came to do them
uh you know were amazing
and did you know such great performances
that we wrestled with cutting them for
about for two years
i would say it took it was a shorter
time
from hey i we have this movie that we
want to make to making the movie
than editing and getting it out there i
mean we edited
many many many versions of this movie
um and one of them on this kind of you
know the original script had these
interviews with family members
uh played by really great actors and
actresses
who gave their time um
and the reason why they were cut was
you know the reason why it took so long
to cut them is because they were so good
but it it took you out of the car it
took you out of the
it gave you like this break in tension
um and it gave it gave the audience a
relief
in a way that uh felt counter
intuitive to the film um i always said i
wanted people to kind of watch this
movie like this
a little bit like and
it kind of allowed you to go like okay
all right
like this is you know
it released the audience from being
stuck in this car with them
you know the way we shot the film
you know the camera always feels like it
never
leaves the confines of the car except
when
there's a few ex there's exteriors where
we go outside to just say like
look how bad it is out here look how bad
it is they don't want to
like they shouldn't get out here because
it's really bad there's nowhere to go
now go back in the car um but we were
fair
we were fairly mindful except for like
two
there's only one key moment where i
purposely wanted the camera to feel like
it was leaving the car
but other than that the camera never
like the lens of the camera never left
what the confines of the car could be so
never left never broke the window frame
it never broke
outside the car so the audience always
felt kind of trapped in there with it
and it's the kind of claustrophobia that
really drives the film so
the 2002 was just kind of uh
a product of the original script being
bait you know
based on these like two movies that were
happening at the same time
one being the movie in the car and one
being the documentary that
is not making it out there into the
world
and whose decision was that to cut the
documentary part was it a group decision
uh
it was a group i mean yeah it was it was
it was a group decision um
i mean in the end it's my decision
uh but
i couldn't convince myself that it was
better with it
you know it was just one of these things
that
um our lead actor or one of our lead
actor
one of our actors has a vincent had this
um
term it was a it was it's you know it's
just like addition by subtraction
um it really just
changed the way eu
saw or experienced the film and
you know once i saw it that way i was
you know you know it was heartbreaking
because it was something that i really
you know we really worked hard to do and
we really
wrote a lot of and uh you know the cast
was great and was shot beautifully and
it was like there was no
you know it was just that um
it didn't it it didn't it took away from
you know the end product so
you know there's that term you have to
like kill your babies and
you know that's one of them that was
that was one of the babies that we had
to kill
to get the movie to where it is
because you said you wanted the audience
to really feel that the intensity of
being trapped
yeah i mean i think the whole wheel i
always thought the audience would feel
that way
you know regardless but as you know
we kind of screened it you know we
tested it
we you know
kept going through the process and there
was just something inside of
me going um it's not as good
like it's better to not have these
interviews here
so it was just a kind of you know i well
explained to the those actors that like
it's
it's like a bad breakup it's like it's
not you it's me
it was my it was it was you were great
but it was like
poor it was it was just it's not didn't
it just didn't work out and like
you're too good for me yeah you're so
good it's not me
i didn't know what i was doing i'm so
sorry
uh we all thought it was a really good
idea and then
it just wasn't as good as this idea was
and you know in hindsight we always were
like let's just do this part later um
but kind of the machine of
um you know
the kind of like well we have everything
here and like the money and the this and
the
the camera and the people to do it like
they're all here so like if we just take
these two days to do it we should just
do get it all done like instead of
waiting and trying to do it again later
so
you